[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and welcome back to the break room it's
uh june 9th you know that what that
means six nine six nine baby i don't
know what it means
uh
this is the break room you all know that
you're all roomies you're all breakers
uh this is our daily show that keeps you
updated on just what's going on in nerd
news i'm
brandon have you met me before uh and
coming up on the show today we've got
news on miss marvel we're finally going
to get into it we got stranger things
news we got she-hulk news and even more
news but before we get on all this news
that i promised you i gotta introduce
who else is on the panel it's starting
on the opposite side of the table we got
researcher anna vance that's me where's
my camera hey
with a little red light so far away
we could bring it closer but that's
that's the micro view they got to pay
for it uh also sitting on the other side
of the table it's jessica clements i
don't miss you
that was cold you broke my heart by
switching to the other side of the table
you're on the other side you're the dark
side i'm on the dark i've gone to the
dark side you see jessica in my opinion
it's the jedi who are evil uh it's
sitting next to me on the dark side we
got uh john back from behind the curtain
the man who runs the machine
that's right my sith name is darth
smelly darth smelly oh that's a good one
you're you're gonna get killed off by
your master real fast okay yeah
if only if there could be only two
you're not gonna make it number two
that's what they say all the time uh as
always here on the break room we've got
uh the chat going and you guys are
flying through the chat and we love you
too uh
but if you send in those super chats you
can unlock our swear jar what's the swag
jar the guy who's here for the first
time is asking well the swear jar gives
us the ability to swear here on the
break room or they're not allowed to
swear the fcc they won't let us be i've
done that one before we got to monetize
yesterday we got demonetized for all the
swearing we did fcc doesn't want to see
your pp they don't want to see my pee
pee and you're not going to see my pee
pee either i promise you but i haven't
made a threat earlier
i can't talk about that that was pretty
shocking
if we get a hundred dollars that's not a
lot of money anna
that's not a lot yeah yeah value
yourself value yourself if we get 100
in the swear jar from multiple chats or
maybe one lovely super chatter uh well
well what else we'll get to swear yeah
uh we're gonna fight for it today no
polls you don't get to decide who swears
today we'll swear should we address zach
being gone no we're not gonna talk about
that we got hit by a train yeah yeah uh
and the train's not doing well
yeah
he's out there fighting trains thomas is
bleeding um if we get two hundred
dollars in the swear john today not only
will anna reveal something that i don't
want to see
god i promise i promise to unleash my
swear jar which is pressure cooking
right now and i would love to let it off
so
get 200 in and we'll get demonetized
give me give me camera four give me your
who's like zach there's no
uh uh
who's normally on the show
there's no datsun
daschle's not even behind the camera i
gotta lean over for camera four um thank
you for sending in your super chats
please be patient with us there's not
going to be any polls today because
we're a little short but uh you know
talk to you talk to yourself don't make
the show so early on we're going to just
give you people
it's going to be a good show immediately
we're like look here look your camera
for go to me really quick
hey okay great thank you uh yeah we're
missing a lot of people jessica and
brandon who are normally on the show
don't matter
of course you guys matter but oh my god
all right let's get in let's get into
some uh i'm sweating let's get the show
started let's start with some headlines
oh hold on
hold on what we got mr krabs oh mr krabs
mr krabs coming in spicy let's start
this one off right with a dollar super
chat
um i think we just broke 100 because we
got a five dollars
to me i don't feel like i deserve
to swear you don't [ __ ] deserve it
john every time you guys break a hundred
we go off on john yeah
actually
[Music]
yeah i don't know how to curse at people
when you're really
absolutely adorable they called me
chuckle [ __ ] middle school
um i want to stay away from every middle
school story you have to show terrible
middle school stories check the replays
dad i did not kill my mom uh thank you
mr krabs again and also thank you just
me who'd rather be a sith than a jedi
hell yeah jedi are messed up someone's
gotta stop those jedi uh let's talk
about these headlines our first big
headline today a couple of exciting new
trailers dropped uh and one of them is
for jordan peele's latest horror film
nope have you seen it john i i will not
see it i i i i say you have to say no
but that's fine
did i i'm not an improviser i'm behind
the scenes ask me nope jessica did you
see it no i don't want to do it now you
already
anna did you see it
but i really like jordan that's me one
more time jessica have you seen the
trailer get out
this is what the energy is going to be
like the whole show
we didn't watch the trailer mainly
because i don't want to see any more of
this movie right i want to i want to go
in fresh i love that first trailer i
finally got to see it in the theaters i
think when i saw multiverse amendments
they had it ahead of that it was so cool
on the big screen so creepy so horror
film i'm a scared little baby boy uh so
i don't like scary movies so i already
hate that i'm gonna have to go see this
movie but i want to be surprised and i
don't want to see any more trailer yeah
i don't need to see it anymore i just
want to see it i had a roommate who
would stand outside of the theater and
listen for nicole kidman before he was
i'm serious he would walk in i gave it
from um
i gauge it from work from here and i'm
like oh 10 minutes i got 10 10 minutes
to get there let me gauge it i i try to
intentionally skip the trailers now
because i'm like i just don't yeah
i don't know we watch so much of like
the marvel trailers and the dc tracks
and we know every little moment we've
watched every little clip and we've
pieced together the whole movie in our
brains give me a trailer i don't have to
watch all i need is nicole that's all we
need
is the only concept i have a-list so i
go into the theater 20 minutes late get
nicole yeah yeah
all i need in this life of sin is nicole
is my girlfriend don't tell my wife uh
we also got a new trailer for stranger
things season four volume two have you
seen it uh i have not seen it
i've seen it have you seen it
no i haven't seen it and have you seen
it i don't want to do this one all right
she hasn't seen it i haven't seen it
either because i have been furnished
volume one what did you just say i
haven't finished volume one of season
four of stranger things yet that's okay
there's so much content there's so do
you think it spoils anything if you
haven't finished yet
okay so that's why i've watched the
trailer there you go i'm on book
we also got a new poster today for
disney pluses she-hulk uh which
highlights the hero's dual identity dash
show i think we got that trailer to show
the folks oh look at that they released
a few of these um we have a couple of
them to show the good folks at home i
think it's really interesting you know
we we just got moon night which was like
this multiple personality show and of
course we've seen you know the duality
of bruce banner and hulk in in you know
the incredible hulk and most recently i
think in infinity war they did a good
job but this is really interesting
they're sort of highlighting
both sides of jennifer walters i wonder
if we're gonna sort of dive into the
sort of psychology of
that they kind of did the same poster
for
wanda vision
um
yeah it was like her normal and then her
the black and white yeah the 50s yeah
i'm wondering you know
the hulk bruce banner that whole thing
was like these are two personalities it
is a d.i.d kind of thing uh this is his
anger personality and this is his normal
personality but that doesn't seem to be
the case for like abomination or for
uh even she-hulk she's kind of the same
she's maybe a little more aggressive
when she's
hulked out yeah maybe we but we did see
blonsky in uh the trailer right not an
abomination anymore back out so he's
back in the morning he'll have both of
those yeah as well she gets a killer
blowout whenever she turns into i don't
know why her hair changes
her roots her roots
oh my god her roots really go great when
she hulks out um
yeah so i'm super excited for this show
i can't wait to see more of it uh
another bit of news that came right
before we put the show together huge
news speaking of straight from deadline
this is the real this is the real juice
uh jake schreier director of paper towns
robert and frank is set to direct marvel
thunderbolts
yeah so this examination was not
announced but you know so many
thunderbolts characters have been
introduced in the mcu um
you know we kind of all saw the writing
on the wall but but deadline got the
scoop they have a director now marvel's
thunderbolts we have no idea when it's
coming out um but you know question for
you guys is you know unfortunately
william hurt passed away earlier last
year um
so we won't have thaddeus ross
presumably right as the leader of the
thunderbolts yeah um where do you think
they'll go with this thunderbolts story
i mean it seems like val right is
putting together thunderbolts uh elaine
from seinfeld she's creating the
thunderbolts she's already recruited uh
u.s agent john walker jenny manny's
himself we call him daddy mayonnaise on
today
jessica calls him daddy manny i call him
daddy mayonnaise because he is still
fine uh and we got elena bolova working
for her who's toeing the line between uh
good advance uh but yeah it seemed like
abomination would fit right in there i
love in the comics the thunderbolts run
uh uh where norman osborne is in charge
of the thunderbolts and everyone thinks
they're great and he's letting like
venom eat people and they're doing bad
things uh and they're acting like the
avengers they dress up like the avengers
but they're really bad i like that
that's super fun
so funny where did we leave off with
zemo at the end of falcon winter soldier
he's just free no he's in prison okay
he's in prison okay took him right okay
are you pointing at me i'm asking you i
don't know you know daddy okay
he turned himself in remember he was
thinking of the old guy that was in the
car who triggered the bomb was it a
there's an old dude and he like blew
himself up
you were talking about mission
i don't know what you're talking about i
haven't seen us up in the chat who where
was he is huge but back in prison for as
much as we know he's facing his crimes
right like a man but i want more
was involved with the thunderbolts
during that run i i i would like to see
him in there i don't know anything about
comics i don't think you know anything
about comics uh some new artwork from
dean sheriff shows that wong was
originally accompanying america chavez
and doctor strange to earth 838 or it
could have been the earth 3 8 3 8
version of wong that found them which
was interesting we didn't see wong in
the 838 we assume he's still there
somewhere but they never mentioned it
yeah yeah maybe it was often commercial
yeah there's a look at this and this is
like conceptual uh
drawing right uh when they're kind of
putting this movie together they
probably realize they all they each had
like something to overcome and then wong
didn't so it was like oh
well longer story doesn't matter
we heard there were a ton of reshoots
for for multiverse of madness and
without sort of getting too far into you
know some of the inside scoops that we
had heard i'm gonna i'm gonna say it
anyways
the um opening of the film um was gonna
include wong in that sort of place where
that ribbon monster thing was and they
were you know i don't remember where
they were the utopia no that wasn't the
youtube empire take that back space
space
yeah so wong was originally going to be
there um and then we also saw that that
reshoot we showed a couple of weeks ago
on the break room of of wong and a
couple of other sorcerers scaling the
mountain undergo so it seems like wong's
role really changed throughout the
production of this film um and you know
i think he ended up in a great place i
really like yeah i mean you're right
about the reshoots because we know they
they they after like one division's
popularity i think and the kind of
rearranging of when things were supposed
to come out they did a lot of research
and those involved the scarlet witch and
if we have her back in our universe or
in the 616
uh threatening someone uh and you you've
taken wong out equation who is she
threatening like who else to convert do
we even care about this rintra no we
don't even know the guy uh so having
here
we don't even know sarah
she died for nothing uh having long bear
uh as kind of like a dramatic could wang
die is he in danger i think that adds a
lot more stakes rather than having him
walking around uh in the eight three
eight
is he just a little piece of fishy bait
though a little bit
being demoted to a little piece of bait
to just dangle in front of bad guys
no i don't think so they let him be the
source of supreme i mean maybe they
don't like him
with a crown oh yeah a little tasty fish
bait um
yeah i like you know obviously i like
what they did
i would like to know where the wong in
the 838 was during all the events that
were going on is he this i because uh
uh uh mordo's the sorcerer supreme right
right they call themselves that's a good
question
yeah maybe
mordo killed wong confirmed um i also
you know disney plus making so many
shows now i would love like wong during
the flip what was he what was he up to
during the blip you just run around
staying busy
kicking ass
making bread yeah i mean i'm sure
i'm sure wong has several development
deals at disney plus because he gets to
be in every mcu property that's the
benedict wong promise right there
uh and miss marvel has officially
debuted as marvel studios highest rated
disney plus show to date with great
reviews and building buzz you know it's
really exciting to see where the series
goes we all love the show i really was
very impressed with the first episode
john seen the second episode and holds
it over our heads constantly we get it
we get it
thank you thank you
thank you thank you
uh we're rebuilding our relationship uh
but this is that thing too right of uh
with the ratings it's like
um
no no not oh this is like critical time
i take it all back the critical equation
is bigger
i thought they were saying it was their
most watched series again
i like that but i don't think i think
it's still loki loki was there like high
they claimed obi-wan is now they'll
claim it well
[Music]
outside company that tried to measure it
but again we don't know this seems it
seems so hard to measure this because i
remember we were talking about the how
they measure who watches uh who like
tunes into uh stranger things versus
obi-wan kenobi and it was like minutes
watch but there's more minutes in star
or stranger things because i had like
six episodes and only one only had two
so it's like how do you guys measure
these things it seems too hard yeah it's
too hard it does seem very hard speaking
of hard time for the break room
breakdown
already
do we got a graphic do we have a graphic
for jess oh thank god
[Music]
filled with shadowy figures is glowing
many of them look balls
carrying spheres
[Music]
it's gonna be more personal to kamala
and her family hernani the purple and
fuchsia tones actually remind me a lot
of the ancestral plane which moon knight
just told us is part of the same mcu
afterlife network as the egyptian
underworld we could be looking at
another spiritual realm that's connected
with the ancestors of the con women
ancestors who might be extraterrestrial
cree or skrull or cree experiments on
the humans the inhumans
apologies for any technical difficulties
i think you got it especially from the
graphics i like the zen music playing
ready to chill out basically eric boss
is breaking down the fact the part where
um
keep going
where when she's got her powers she's at
avenger con she goes down and then
there's just a plane which people here
assume is the astral plane of the people
with the you see the eyes cape
dark glowing eyes
and the bald head there's a lot of them
kind of resemble that of the watcher and
i see your guys as super chats and i do
want to address um
i can't read you said it's nfls mls
beads said do you think kamala's mom is
a scroll we also got mo said i think
kamala's grandmother was a villain
scroll and we have pentimente
uh oh we'll answer this at the end
because that's a good overall that
brings up a good point i just want to
address everyone and say [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you you don't get the birds yeah we
do over 200.
everybody that tip said i want to see
you call him a chuckle [ __ ] oh no
everyone you're loving
sorry i was looking for her childhood
nickname from her mom but you can curse
me out as much as you no i love you i
need my camera yes i summoned it just by
pointing at it incredible
chuckle [ __ ] okay
so i do want to address what was
happening on the astral plane but i also
think we need to talk about what the
heck is up with kamala's grandma yeah a
lot of questions about this one
i love when um ml says i think kamala's
grandmother was a villain
scroll and then do you think kamala's
mom is the squirrel i agree with you too
i think you guys are on the okay well i
agree with you i think you guys are on
the right track because i'm still
holding on to the fact that in the
comics that they were like oh she's a
little bit of cree because the cree
blended with them blended had sex
or it's from tech the cree tech so i
think her grandma or and i think that
line of her family has cree in them or
just knows kree tech very well it
definitely wasn't for nothing that line
her mom had in the car that's like oh i
shouldn't be surprised that you're a
dreamer like my mom was too or something
like that like that definitely wasn't
for nothing 100 it was i'm holding on to
that in the fact that like the mom
didn't care that bruno created that like
super amazon echo for them
he she was immediate the dad was like
this is crazy and the mom's like
yeah whatever and i was like yeah it's
because you've been to space probably
right
like her mom has that conversation with
her after she gets back from avenger con
that's like do you want to be
you know the girl that we raise or do
you want to be this cosmic whatever
and and to me that reads of like oh i'm
afraid that my child is going to be
something that i've seen you know that i
know maybe this is a a little bit like
halloween town is that the one where the
mom's like
suppresses her powers
because she was a witch too i think
amazon is something that would make for
a great story that she was like i want
you to have my power i want you to take
this bangle and the mom was like no i
see what it's done to families like it
was too much for you i'm not going to be
on that track i'm going to raise my
family like a normal family not
superhero or moana's grandma who's like
moana you gotta get out there you gotta
go you get explored you gotta get out
and then dad's like no we gotta stay
here everyone dies when they go over the
waves and grandma's like i'm dying and
everyone cries oh wow do you guys
yeah so you guys in the chat um since we
don't have the polls but i do want to
see your guys's chat if you guys also
agree that maybe this is the grandma was
a scroll or crea and is evil or not evil
um i think that's i love emo's piece
because i'm just like that is a good
take i didn't think of the grandma as
evil and i don't want to believe that
grandma's evil um and then are we
actually witnessing the ancestral plane
is this the ancestral plane at first i
screamed at john and i said john you're
an idiot this is not their special thing
and then i rewatched that breakdown
scene and i missed it the first time i
watched it so i did i was like what are
you talking about call me a chuckle [ __ ]
one more time
i swear
yeah that's it's a really good question
you know we at new rockstars love to
talk about colors a lot and you know we
do see
this purple motif in the ancestral plane
where we've seen it in wakanda and we've
seen it in uh moon night and now we're
seeing the same sort of purple motif
here what i will say is
this
this the glowing eyes and the sort of
like you know silhouetted figures feels
scarier to me than any other ancestor i
think it's a warning i think it's like
the purple is also a dark magic thing
it's the dark dimension it uses a lot of
purple so these could be like evil
things that uh in the which has done a
lot in horror movies when you mess with
it like we saw in dr strange's
multiverse of menace when you mess with
the dark side they start coming for you
right right and now that she's like
alerted them to that her presence now
they could start coming for her do you
think that okay do you do you agree with
uh
i almost called him brandon do you agree
with white woman eric voss that it
possibly is the watcher or like i don't
i don't know about the watches only
because there were so many but what i
think is you see these like kind of bald
heads right which uh the skrulls when
they're in squirrel form they have like
a ball you think we don't see the ears
and if if it is where like this
technology is cree related these could
be all the scrolls that could that the
cree have killed that are like oh you
one of them you agree we're coming for
you do you agree with what brandon is
saying you guys
do you agree with me so well on that
point something that we didn't include
here in in this clip but eric mentions
later is you know the um cree supreme
intelligence has the sort of ability to
manifest your greatest desires or or you
know
manifest to you you know what you want
to see or whatever and um
you know with this bracelet
kamala is able to like use light powers
similar to sort of what she's always
dreamed of being you know superhero and
all that kind of thing
so he was kind of saying like that leads
us to think maybe it is a cree piece of
technology that is using some of that
like supreme intelligence juice uh
whatever you want to call it uh to
manifest something for her that she's
always kind of dreamed of so i think
we're i think we're barreling toward
korea we've got we've got miss marvel
coming up in the marvels um you know
obviously like that movie will probably
deal with scrolls or creed to a certain
degree um so yeah i think it makes a lot
of sense do we think that the bengals
actually have magic in them or do we
think that this is a cause some people
are like it's magical bangles and i'm
like i think it's tech i think it's tech
because i'm still holding on to the i
was all known from the comics that bruno
um made the bangles and adjusted them so
it could help her with her powers to
support her make it easier to control
but in this it still could be tech but
just created something right bruno this
tech that looks like magic yeah much
like uh shanxi in the ring yeah the
rings yeah those those use magic but
they look very tech with their their
nature so it's also very possible that
in a future episode bruno could mess
with the bangles to like unlock more
power something like that how smart is
bruno i mean to be fair
he's using a gopro they sell much
smaller
uh wi-fi enabled cameras and he took a
alexa which is very small and just made
it bigger
the photon gloves that he made were just
like little yeah
you two become fathers
i mean like listen son i really like
what you're doing but it's terrible it's
like
um in the comics he's he's incredibly
smart he's basically like peter parker
okay um towards the middle of the comics
he leaves and goes to wakanda to study
and he gets a scholarship and like when
he's in wakanda all the kids are like
this is the scholarship kid uh this is a
scholarship
but he's incredibly smart um and it's
really hard to get into those schools in
wakanda so it's like holy crap so he's
legit smart legit and this he also
there's still differences and i like
that they keep it different between the
comics and this because i don't want
everyone to be like i have to read the
comments it's like no you can get into
it without the comments like it's just
fine i do like when they sort of
uh take a lot of inspiration from the
comics though right like because it
almost gives you something that you love
it it gives you an opportunity to go you
know
get something slightly different but
still the same thing that you love
so everyone in the chat immediately went
to we don't talk about bruno that's true
and uh if he became if he becomes evil
we will shout it in the streets do we
know where this lands in the mcu
timeline yes they said uh one to two
years after avengers end game so i don't
know where that places it between
some other phase four properties but so
that makes sense why they like chose for
avengers con there was like a lot of
specific avengers chosen right and then
there's loki it's a really quick way
that's a quick timeline to set up a
whole convention a nighttime convention
by the way
i'm very obsessed with this convention
it seemed like a trap do you mind i
think maybe the dodc put the convention
it reminded me of
uh pinocchio's pleasure island where you
walk in
200
you know pinocchio's pleasure island
you'll learn all about in the
live-action pinocchio coming to disney
places
stop right uh yeah i was suss at that
whole convention it seemed really shady
i don't trust it um but it would be
interesting if it is something like the
dodc is using to find them all uh uh aj
stan 1991 wants us to do a whole uh dodc
recap video yeah which they've been
involved in the mcu for a long time they
go all the way back to like game two
department of damage control oh yes yes
yes yes they're in the
superman
and i think they're in superman it's a
great flick
crossover and eric pointed out how like
uh you know agent p cleary uh he's a
little
suspect right he's really interested he
doesn't seem like he's surprised by her
powers could he be a skrull hiding out
he know he knew about nick fury and his
activities was that the guy who wasn't
inventing anna uh he wasn't inventing
anna yes he's also he's also in uh
succession great in succession he can't
help but notice in the comments someone
said why are we italian all of a sudden
and it's because john's italian italians
john smith
they come sleeping
paintamenti thank you for your super
chat asks would you all rather have
cosmic powers or in biggin powers if you
were in the mcu cosmetics cosmetics i
think we are all i mean i feel cosmic
too i'm going begging just to be the the
okay so that means nothing to them
i like that she can kind of like use
distance attacks right i mean i suppose
if you can stretch slides into like body
horror kind of eerie so quick that's
funny
i wouldn't mind scaring people you could
scare people in a bank and then rob it
really but imagine like you go to the
you you go to costco you get a lot of
items and you got 10 trips to make
upstairs no you got one trip with your
jar your hands
you carry all your groceries up in one
hand i love you guys i'm thinking
outside the box i love that you can also
just put them on a little glow cube
boring i'm just so bored with your
cosmic powers some people in the chat
thinking that bruno is a scroll they're
everyone in the show is a scroll so i
think later on we'll recognize and
they've already talked about it a little
bit um but there is definitely a bad
person in the lineup
that we've already like seen in the
trailers they've talked about in the
cast
and this is honestly based off of the
comics when i read i hit the mic i
stopped the comics when i read them and
i love it he is a great
i can't wait for you guys to see it if
it happens but how are you gonna put
that character in and say he's not evil
um any more super chats
uh we did just get one from chrissy
yeah so all right chrissy says we can
move on uh but but first we'll get to
chrissy's
question we asked you a question johnny
just tell them
if the color or effect of your magic was
determined by your personality what do
you think each other's magical color
i mean jessica's purple i'd want it to
be purple but what should be like yellow
oh and i don't have a problem i just
want purple golden shower
i'm not talking about i'm not telling
you i'm not tommy or anna so
i like that green magic that like uh uh
classic loki used
i like a little green shine on the magic
i think you're gonna look like you're
giving off stink lines that's fine i'm
stinky i have an obsession with
halloween um and all things witches i
think if i could i would i would have
you know some some of that wanda magic
the maroon you're like uh morbius
demanding the reds
yeah purple purple is my favorite color
you can take purple because pink is my
favorite color
amazing
we're all beautiful together uh we are
all beautiful together and we all love g
fuel that's right
we want to uh thank g fuel for working
with us they have some lovely flavors
you guys want me to chug this right now
i don't i don't want you i do actually
no no i want to watch you um
you guys know about g fuel it's used by
athletes it's used by uh
gamers it's used by youtube
personalities all over the place uh g
feels great it's got no sugar in it
that's right it's got all natural
ingredients that right uh and it's got
so many delicious flavors whoa
oh my god why not oh zach's gonna be
pissed uh this is what we don't know
this is a rare limited edition
red ooze oh i'm sorry
please don't tell zach that we've done
that we gotta hide that we gotta reseal
that he's gonna kill us he won't know um
uh but we do wanna thank you for
watching us we have our own affiliate
link and it's correctly spelled right
now on the screen and it's also in the
description of this video if you head to
g fuel dot l y slash new rockstars you
will get 10 off your order now do you
feel it has caffeine you can probably
tell because uh jessica is literally
vibrating
but they do sell a caffeine freeze
version that we don't have on the table
because we love it so much it's called
their like hydration line which is more
about like giving you those electrolytes
making you feel refreshed what mr crab
said sweet sweet g diesel
baby when it comes to fuel this is
definitely diesel okay it'll power you
i'll put [ __ ] uh you'll be the optimus
prime of your your automobile friends um
but we we do like g fuel we use a lot uh
so thank you g fuel check it out get
some g food for you guys link right
today so we got the link right hit it
get it for yourself get 10 off uh it's
probably more than you're paying in the
taxes for it also we want to send you
all over to newrockstarsmerch.com
where you can find our latest latest
succession shirt we actually got two
latest obsessions going right now one's
our empire's most wanted based on
obi-wan kenobi but we also just released
it's up on the site now cosmic daydream
based on miss marvel this is a latest
obsession shirt look at it beautiful
it's got that style of miss marvel uh
it's a limited edition shirt uh once
it's gone it's gone for good we won't
sell it again when you buy this shirt
though you do unlock the ability to get
a shout out on our inside marvel which
after show for miss marvel which is
hosted by mt and eric boss
and they might even read your shout out
live on the air but either way it'll
appear on the show it's great
it also unlocks two minutes of free time
for tommy where he gets to escape the uh
the office yeah we ended that program
we ended that program so we didn't tell
tommy we ended it but uh we didn't did
um so be sure to check out all of our
merch options over at
newrockstarsmarch.com and check out our
tumblr it's me
jessica's running on tumblr right now i
was lacking slacking and protracting
for a minute but i was back last night
and i was posting a lot of stuff for
miss marvel and talking about ms marvel
some folks so if you want to jump on
tumblr and just you know chat
stuff with me it's pride month hang out
with us yeah yeah check out our tumblr
if you've never used tumblr before uh
get on there check it out if you had it
years ago and you need to reset your
password do that and go on tumblr uh but
check out our official new rockstars
tumblr please jessica's killing it over
there catch up on my john locke fanfic
too please
i'm actually more of a moriarty asian
sherlock shipper
oh this is sherlock
it was either oh this is sherlock
philosophy or lost
i was like damn okay i guess if you want
to do that
that's next month so i'm morphing them
all together i've been writing my fan
fiction
i love that bald guy get lost
speaking of lost
it's upper mandatory fun where's my
camera oh boom play that graphic yes
mandatory fun but it's not fun if we
play it for once so let's play for two
play it again
tommy coming out of jessica i'm trying
not to but i might have to go use the
bathroom and pee because we play it for
three play it for three give it to me
too much
you guys i'm not gonna go to four i'm
not gonna go to four because then i'll
have to hit the floor um
you guys it is
mandatory fun hosted by jessica clements
tommy's out
he got hit by a bus mommy's out and you
should see the devices
public transportation in l.a county has
been disrupted because tommy and zach
are on the loose bus
yes they yeah yeah it is they are
menacing
and they only go for public
transportation they they think of it i
hate it i hate it they're simps for the
auto industry i know
just like detroit so anyways it's
mandatory fun and today for mandatory
fun i chose something toxic
something toxic i'm gonna need each of
you guys to grab a red and green flag
which is the bad one that you wanted to
give to brandon i already fixed it oh
what a sweetie what a sweet enough you
guys we're gonna play uh red flag green
flag and like you've probably seen i'm
gonna have some marble cinematic
universe oh prompts right here is this i
feel like i'm on a late-night talk show
john and sam made these because it took
them three hours to put those things
right i have some problems here
and um those in the chat you can always
put up the red flag emoji or you can
just say yelp red flag as loud as you
can in that chat when i say that all
caps i have these prompts and i want on
the count of three yeah explain you guys
i'm an old man so you're going to keep
your flags down okay the count of three
i'm gonna i'm gonna re or i'm gonna read
the prompt i'm gonna count to three and
then you put up if it's a green flag or
a red flag and the green flag is good to
go red flag is probably is a problem and
then the number three is after yeah one
two three
yeah you guys is not rock paper scissors
it comes after two let's hear it one two
three go
what is the question
i was just practicing okay okay you guys
ready this show is unedited yes okay you
guys ready
i'm ready they dress up as loki at
avengercon
they dress up as loki at avengercon oh
sorry one
two
three
shoot i'm so torn
okay no there's no wait
flag hidden red flag behind it no no no
you can't spell it i'm a person in the
mcu i live in the mcu i'm a person in
this world you're a brazilian
big red flag they don't know how they
don't know how good this is like you
know you choose
yeah you choose whatever you can choose
as a partner as a friend but either way
they're dressing up as loki
is that a green flag or a red flag i'm
just changing it to deadpool and putting
up a red flag look at all the red flags
i understand i understand why you would
think red flag off the bat i want to
hear your fight for me here's why go
against the grain a little bit show up
play the villain it's so much more fun
to go to a con as a villain because then
everyone is like trying to interact with
you and you're like having a good time
what brandon said he's a he's a menace
he's a terrorist that's really
technically that's you showing up
dressed as timothy mcveigh the oklahoma
city bomber
it's a problematic that is true you know
if we can't lampoon our terrorists gay
bishop almost died her father died loki
killed her father that's true well her
stepfather that was into some shady [ __ ]
you guys it don't matter
we got we got another one we got another
ones and i'm gonna count to three and
then you and then you lift the flag
ready okay when you figure out he's a
sleeper agent but has a really cool
bionic arm classic when you find out
he's a sleeper agent but has a really
cool bionic arm
one
two
three hell yeah no no way
no way bionic
what are the 13 words some random person
on the street could look up and uh yeah
i'm not 13.
well you're one off thank god uh
the bionic arm is cool but if he's a
sleeper agent it's like oh i could say
anything he could be quick and then he
can be out it does make me it makes me
think of when like uh uh wolverine in
the first x-men movies he's dreaming and
he stabs rogue right like you got you
got to be careful you guys saying green
in the chat i want to know why i need to
know why i guess oh my god
when they can change to any size when
they can change to any size baby
one okay two i mean three i
the man versus the women the boys who
watch the boys
[Music]
[Applause]
and you tell them
they couldn't have an open casket well
they could have an open half casket they
couldn't open the bottom half oh my god
it's very mixed in the chat i'm getting
a lot of greens
too many greens a lot of greens getting
relaxed
aside for your own health
we've had a lot of fun today okay okay
i got a couple more
when he says he's into crystals then he
kills half the universe
when he says he's into crystals but then
he kills half the universe okay
three
two
one
here's the thing when you get married to
someone what is theirs becomes yours
yeah i want those stones oh yeah i want
those stones i don't care if they kill
me i will um
i'll be i don't know what can't you do
with infinity stones no no no no no i
have no sense of self-preservation
everything is a green flag to
and it's not a good thing it's not a
good thing they're setting them out in
the full moon
they're putting them by the bedside you
got covered they're rubbing uh an
amethyst on your forehead get them you
also got to think right like thanos was
away for so many years just crystal
hunting yeah that was a lonely
time also would you get offended when he
didn't kill you and he killed his
daughter it's fully random
no no he had to kill
okay ready got two more two more okay
iron man
that's it iron man period
three oh wait
is it with pepe it's just ironic
that's iron man every baggage that comes
with iron man
three
two
one
you guys are wild you guys are watching
think about yes think about the money
think about that woman that cornered him
in civil war and was like my son died
because of yeah
that first movie the 15 minutes was just
solid red flag yeah yeah he's a change
tell it to me when we're hanging out on
our private beach right having a great
time wow you guys about money but as
soon as uh a pee hole run into it that's
why you don't want to die
[Applause]
what amount of money would make you get
in there get up in there
honestly if i had to do it for iron man
sure okay last one last one you guys
last one in the chat too many greens in
the chat too many greens in there we
have all sorts of colors
cancelling mandatory fun we got one more
um okay ready
you exchange numbers at the club
and they have a new asgard area code you
exchanged numbers at the club and they
got a new asgard area code ready
three
two
[Music]
red one i'm i'm i live in la i'm not
even going to santa monica to date
someone i ain't going out that's true i
didn't think like you wouldn't go to you
wouldn't go to norway for uh
in rush hour are you kidding me also
where is what does new eyes guard look
like right now is it still being built
no there's like there's an amusement
park there there's goats you can run on
so you want to live at disneyland well
here's the thing i in this in this
hypothetical i'm imagining that me and
valkyrie have really hit it off and i
absolutely i would go to the new house
guard for about also if you get it if
you get an ass guardian you're dating an
asgardian you're you're about a blip in
their life you know i mean they're gonna
live for five thousand years
you're you're just you're just there for
a little fun you have some fun time plus
depending on when you hit him uh you
know they might got they've saved up a
lot of money someone someone did say you
could have a child that's a demigod
that's right you can have a child well
and so as a child
as a kid who has a dead parent um
this always happens you know
[Laughter]
my name is bruce um no i you know uh i
imagine if you're gonna live for like 15
000 years or however long as guardians
live for it doesn't it doesn't sting
quite as much if you're immortal
mushroom dies that's true i mean i still
put a green flag because i just assumed
they had it because they're strong they
could do a little magic you know what i
mean they got access to the goats it's
great
that was red flag green flag thank you
guys for playing i don't know too much
about each and every one of you and also
a big [ __ ] thank you to mls beads uh
allowing us to curse away give him a
chuckle [ __ ] he paid for it paid for
that truck
oh that's a big chunk
that's a big chuckle [ __ ] i hate this
game i also i can't do that anymore but
someone called you girls naughty girls
and i think that's from the uh the size
changing thing
like a tree and and jack or maybe
jacques uh calling out jess specifically
it was a green flag for everything baby
we got some freaks in the chat that's
right and i love to see it speaking of
freaks in the chat uh i'm at the desk
today
it's my turn for a freaking segment and
you know we want to talk a little bit
about thor love and thunder as we're
just talking about new asgard we just
got some cool
news
from both natalie portman and from chris
hemsworth they gave an interview in the
d23 magazine just like a disney
publication they put out um
talking about the fact that we're gonna
see some flashbacks to their breakup
in thor love and thunder um now they
said they were gonna kind of play it for
comedy a little bit um we saw a little
bit of that in the trailer where you
know thor was like oh has it been like
two three yeah i don't know she was like
how has it been two three years and thor
was like it's been eight years six
months and five days or whatever um
uh yeah so so that is like an
interesting piece of news i want to know
from you guys sort of like let's get to
the bottom of this breakup is it sort of
a red flag green flag like we've been
talking about not smart to date a god do
you think tell me about it
um
do you think they'll kind of i mean
there's too many questions but but let's
start there let's start there what what
caused the breakup well i think it's a
red flag oh i guess was it she broke up
with him yes and it yes it seems that
way uh it does seem like it comes with
too much baggage i think it kind of uh
mirrors that of doctor strange and
christine where it was just like you had
to be in control too too often like and
he's gonna go out and fight uh ultron
and find out all these things and he's
worried about asgard and he's always
like that i mean yeah it's fun at first
right he's picking you up he's carrying
you around the house you're having a
good time he's got a great body it's all
fun and games but then you got to
explain every pop culture reference to
this guy he doesn't get anything you're
trying to watch shows he doesn't know
what's going on it's boring as hell uh
he you know you you introduce them to
your friends they're all fawning over
him they're not talking about you
anymore it's annoying okay
and i think and another point is like
she
got into some real trouble yeah i was
about to say you know you also get
infected with the ether yeah uh stolen
by the dark elves and almost caused the
convergence on earth so maybe not the
healthiest relationship and there's like
a two-week treatment when you get stuck
with the ether when you get infected
with the ether it's really yeah yeah the
doctor's appointments are way out in the
future and you got to meet
you got to meet your partner's parents
and their guys also and it's like this
whole thing i see the person in the chat
saying long distance and i'm like i'm
gonna tell you well you when you have
the power of the bifrost i mean i don't
know i was in a long distance
relationship yeah but every time he's
showing up on in the living room he's
burning
into that floor it's not good you need
to buy a new rug every other week
he wasn't using it words are all fine
and good but actions are where it
matters
during adventures right like yeah let's
go get me give me that
after authority goes back right and
during adventures he doesn't come to
visit uh at all because the bypass is
broken i can't come see you except he
does show up and doesn't even go see it
he doesn't even go see her and then he
goes back with loki to be honest
controversial opinion but in the first
thor movie i thought i thought they both
were the most boring like lacking
chemists we don't talk about that first
horror movie
i was never rooting for them that's all
i'm waiting for now so the follow-up
question is okay we've had their breakup
the movie's called thor love and thunder
we got that line from the um the ticket
release trailer that came out by the way
eric foster breaking that down i think
that's going to be on the channel
tomorrow some cool things that he found
so stay tuned for that but we got that
line from gore who said you're not like
the other gods and then thor says i have
something to fight for so my question
for you guys is this will they end the
movie together no i don't want them back
together thor yeah
let's hope so
no we say no why i i don't think i think
this should just be the resolution that
he's craving so bad it's clear he's
hurting right every other movie we've
seen him in he brings it up in a weird
way and tries to brush it off he needs
that closure you know thor was a he was
a guy he would hit it and quit it he
didn't give a crap right but he met this
earth girl who turned him crazy uh and
now he needs to say he needs to close
this boring earth girl who's so smart uh
he needs to close the book i don't want
them back together did you ask if
they're getting back together he needs
that resolution yeah do they end this
movie i
you don't understand i have to do my
taxes still what
you guys i forgot until now i just woke
up from a
long slit a long slumber i also don't
want them together um i just i don't i
don't i don't want them together she's
she's straight up powerful she's great
she's fine she's doing great on her own
you don't need you don't need no man do
you think she ends this movie still
powered
well i don't think she ends this movie
well i will say randy burnside which
what a name randy burnside was asking
was thor not bringing the hammer oh yeah
i mean
maybe he couldn't
perform you know what i mean a little
whiskey uh little whiskey probably
a little
[Laughter]
you know we see we see you know uh zeus
give the old flick
and toss his robes off and everyone
faints but maybe that's because it was
so incredibly small
maybe i look like a flircan down there
with like things spinning around and uh
a little a little mole face action going
on
all about the hammer okay it's not all
of it it's about the hilt right if
you're me it's a lot about the hammer
let me get that clear right now
um it's all about him
let me tell you let me tell you right
now
also i get i see a lot of people in the
chat that are immediately saying no
she's not going to die
yeah i think it's
experienced gaming being like john no
i know i don't want her to die either
but uh well
no as i say is the no really coming from
a no you don't want it or no
it's not gonna i would love for her to
stick with the power because i want thor
to transition into an odin role not as
like leader of asgard but as like an
older god a wiser god and no longer this
like tool of of power and lightning and
thunder i want him to be a more wisened
character and to grow i want her to also
keep her powers but i want her to stay
on the story line of like it is damaging
her um i just and not because it's a
good thing clearly i just think it
brings a lot of story to it gives a lot
of depth of that character and
we already immediately love jane we we
love her yeah she's boring but like we
still loved her and even what if i still
loved her and so like having that
character be going through this like
trial is really sad and i want her i'm
rooting for her i mean listen i hope she
survives i just hope she gets a
personality a lot oh my god wow
y'all thought i was mean though
didn't offer much in that first movie
either so like i think they both need to
have their own thing anna just watched
thor one and she has notes like listen
yesterday i have yeah he's gotta stop
dying his eyebrows i think that's right
i think we're gonna get both i think
jane's gonna die i think thor is gonna
sort of move on from this mantle of god
of thunder and i think valkyrie is the
one who's gonna kind of step into that
role because she
you know i i think we it would be great
to get a lot more of her i think like
for jane's story that makes a lot of
sense for chris hemsworth's career that
makes a lot of sense and i would love to
get cool valkyrie movies i think we're
all um
not
not rudy is not the right word i think
we're all put in valkyrie much higher
than we should and when i say that i say
that as in like she
is tired she is so tired even in that
trailer in the meeting she was just like
right i don't want to i don't want to do
all this i think she misses the fight i
think she misses the fight and i don't
think she wants to be like tied to a
whole country and a whole a lot of
people she's like i'm me i'm this and
especially because she's still valkyrie
so it's like i think she wants to be
with other valkyries so like it's not
like she you know she cleaned up her act
she stopped drinking she's feeling great
living in asgard and then thor falls off
the wagon and she's like i guess i have
to do this now yeah now i have to see
the bed uh and i agree i think she is
tired of it and she wants to be back out
in space it would be fun if she ends the
movie with the guardians and is like
you stay on earth thor i gotta i want to
go have some fun you're gonna go party
again valkyrie and james so that's what
i wanted that's what i wanted
a little bit right there's a lot of
clips of them together
well there's also like we have
confirmation that she has a girlfriend
in this movie right we have confirmation
who is it
or uh
valkyrie
is a girl i thought we had heard that
that was going to be applied in this
movie
i don't know i don't know maybe i'm
wrong
tell us in the chat if you want that
yeah yeah
if you want to ship uh valkyrie and jane
put it in the chat
like and subscribe if you want valkyrie
do we want to let's go over some of
these super chats yeah let's see um
you know
fray girl great uh moderator in our chat
thank you so much for super chatting she
had a very lovely thing to say she says
i love you anna my favorite banana i
love you jess soul sister love you john
the host with the most sister she said
sista okay
[Laughter]
um love you brandon
big boy brand oh
i don't want to see scary movies that's
just scary
um no thank you so scary let's see note
together can we all say note together we
should see nope together we probably we
probably all will so we've already seen
up together i will say one thing i do
want to see about this breakup from thor
and jane is i want a good meme template
all a marriage story uh with scarlett
johansson and madame driver you know i
want thor to hit the wall like come on
you remember a marriage story anyone
everyone remember i mean anyone out
there remember america it came out like
two years ago
right now it's a classic it's a classic
it's a classic name you all know you're
amazing what's a maymay is that shakira
oh my god no i'm joking i know what a
meme is oh everything hurts
stay tuned to the break room tomorrow
we're going to be talking about all this
cool nerd stuff as well tommy
threatens to be back if the buses will
leave him alone tommy will come back uh
and it will be a friday and our fridays
get crazy around here as if this was
saying we might be hosting our own
avenger con oh we might have a little
cosplay action happen tomorrow
for who has the best one oh yeah maybe
we'll turn to you guys uh to figure that
out we also asked before you head out
today hit that little like button down
there you know don't be afraid to hit it
give it a little thumbs up uh if you're
a green flag hit that hit that like
button if you're a red flag hit the
dislike button any kind of engagement no
i'm kidding um also this is harder to do
but it would it would really we would
really appreciate it if you have
a person in your life who is like
talking about marvel way too much like
we are send them this video just send
them a little break room um i think it's
like a fun time to like i don't have a
ton of marvel fans friends in my life so
luckily i get this at work but if i
didn't have this the break room is like
my version of hanging out and talking
about all the cool marvel stuff yeah or
maybe you have a if you have an enemy
send them the video give them a great
warning of our mandatory fun because
we're wild and so are you guys in the
chat honestly i saw you i saw your red
flags and green flags you guys are you
guys are nasty in the chat you're all
nasty
anna you want him with a chuckle [ __ ] on
the way out just for a good measure
you don't have the money for it just
give him one give him a chuckle [ __ ]
come
okay thank goodness well we thank you
for joining us today happy six nine
everybody and we hope you join us
tomorrow right here on the break room
goodbye rumi
[Music]
strength
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
streaming
[Music]
[Music]
you